で それであのこれからあの経典に見られるユーモア
ブッダは優しく 楽しく
面白く語る だからユーモアというよりは
優しく 楽しく 面白く それが仏教的なユーモアなんです
しかし 私には期待しないでください
お釈迦様はそういうふうに語るんです
えーと 休憩しますか？どうしますか？今 1時間ぐらいは
え？キリがいいんです
とてもいいんです うん
では あの 10分 はい  10分で逃げないで戻ってください
後半は面白いんです はい
では後半始まります 経典の中で
この優しく 面白く 楽しく
難しい論理をどう語っているのかっていうところで
一つ一つテーマを入れて
またスライドにないものも大量にデータがありますので
あの これはブラームナさん曰くアッコウサカスッタという経典ですね
あるバラモンが釈尊に言いたいほど誹謗非難
侮辱 誹謗中傷というのをしたんです
このエピソードでございまして
このかなりの立場のあるバラモンなんです
このバラモン人というのは
インドではね まあ一応
4つのカーストのね 宗教カーストであって
もう社会ではかなり立場があるんですよ
で この人の友達でもであった
このかなりのバラモン人の中でもすごいカーストの上
有名な人がお釈迦様と話し合ったところで出家しちゃったんです
これでバラモン人の宗教に泥を塗ったということになりまして
泥を塗っちゃったんではないかと
で この人はお釈迦様に対して怒ったんです
なんで私の友達を出家されたのかと
怒って ものすごい怒って
お釈迦様に会って ものすごく怒って
もう人間に言わない アサッバーヒパルサーヒワーチャーヒアコウセティパリバセティ
お釈迦様をものすごく侮辱するんです
怒鳴ったり 侮辱したり
言いたい放題のこと そこでお釈迦様は待ってるんです
本人喋ってるんだからね
それも一つ仏教のポイントなんです
相手が喋り出しちゃうと
こちらもういい途中でいろいろ話さすでしょ
あれって頭の悪いんですよ
人が喋ってるならば喋らせた方がいいんです
終わるまで しかし 時間もないんだったら
時間が時間が終わりましたから帰りますと
いうことで十分です で
彼が疲れ切るまで沈黙を守った釈尊がこのように語る
あなたの家を親戚が客か訪ねたとしましょう
お釈迦様のこのパーリ語であるよ
全部彼がもう侮辱して侮辱して怒鳴って終わったら
なんのことなくパーリ語であんたどう思いますかと
そういうふうに始まるんです
あんたどう思いますか？自分の家に
誰かの友達とかね もう血縁関係の親戚とか
あるいはお客とか 時々来たりするでしょうと
うん そうでしょうと その時あなたはね
時々ごちそうを作ったりもするでしょうと
そのあなたはごちそうを作って接待しますか？その時
ちょっと打ち間違いありますけど
はい そのようにしますと
だから普通に喋りますから
喋ります そういう客が来たら
あんたまあまあ 毎日じゃないかもしれませんだけど
結構ごちそう 腕を振るってごちそうしたりする場合もありますね
でもありますよと 本人まだ怒ってますけど
ありますけどという感じで
もし来る予定の客が現れなかったら
あの食事に何をするんですかね
たくさんごちそう作ったんですけど
まあ客が来なかったらあんたどうしますかねと
で 答えはごちそうなので
私と家内と子供たちで食べますと
今 お釈迦様の答え もう本人から質問して答えをもらったんだからね
今あなたは私に誹謗中傷
非難 侮辱などの侮辱などの接待をしましたが
残念ながら私はそれを受け取らないんです
受け取らないので その誹謗中傷
非難 侮辱をあなたと家内と子供たちで受け取ってくださいと
一発で解決するんです
だから怒ったら 我々は怒られたらね
何するんですかね？お釈迦様どうですかね
これがお釈迦様 すごい強烈にユーモアを使ったところなんです
しかし ユーモアでは終わらないんです
言い返しもしているんです
かなり倍 これまたインド文化考えるとかなり厳しいんです
このインドでは この呪いの言葉いっぱいかけるんです
別に人が呪い 呪いかけたんだからって呪われるわけじゃないんだけど
でも気持ち悪いでしょうね
それでバラモン人がインド人を脅してるんだから
自分たちが呪文知ってるんだとかね
神と直接連絡できるんだとかどうかね
全部嘘ですけど あの それで一般人が怖いんですね
だからバラモン人が罰当たりとかね
死んでしまえとか 草に踏む歩いてる途中で
もう野生の草にでも踏まれた方がいいやとか言われると
一般の人々はすごく怖くなるんです
そういう言葉いっぱい言ったんで
この人は それでお釈迦様
すごくニコニコと このあなたの接待はね
ちょっと受け取りませんから
本人も先に言ったんだからね
ごちそうは客が取らなかったら誰が取るのかと
自分と自分の家内と子供たちですからね
まんまとはめているんです
で みんなでどうぞ で おそらくこのバラモンがこう言われたところで
もうものすごい呪いの言葉とか
全部自分の家族に返ってきたんだから
彼がこう言うんです まあそうでないんですけど
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
よくブラフマのアッコサンタンパッチャッコウセティ
侮辱する人に侮辱を返すならば
ローセンタンパティローセティ
えーと 怒った人に逆に怒るならば
バンダンタンパティバンドティ
喧嘩する人に対して逆に喧嘩を売るならば
するならば アヤンゴッチャディブラフマナサンブンジャティヴィーラティーティ
それが接待を受けたことになるんだよと
だから相手が侮辱すると
私もまた侮辱の言葉を返しちゃうと侮辱を受けたんですよ
受けたんだから反応してるでしょ
例えば人がお前死んだ方がましだ
あんた何言うのか そんなことはとか言っちゃうと
もう受けているんです
呪いを だから我々はもう無知だから
いとも簡単に人の非難
侮辱は受け取っちゃうんです
受けたら苦しいんですよ
だからお釈迦様は言うのは黙っていなさいよと
別に そうすると自分が受け取ったことにならないんだと
テーマヤンタヤーネーオサンブンジャーマナヴィーティハラーマ
それらの非難 侮辱は私は受け取りませんので
タウェーウェタンブラフマナホーティタウェーウェタンブラフマナホーティと二回言うんです
だからこれはあなたのものになるんだよ
本当にあなたのものになるんだよ
今まで言ったことは私は受け取れませんよと
それでバラモン人がバワンタンコゴータマサラジカパリサエーワンジャーナティ
あーゴータマのことはね
王様を含むすべての人々はね
この偉い人々はね このように知ってますよと
アラハンサマノゴータマと
沙門が阿羅漢であると
悟った人であると 王様であら
大臣たちやらね 偉い人々はみんな言い張ってますよと
アタチェパナンバワアタチェパナバワンゴータマクッジャティ
なのに釈尊が怒っているでしょうと
お釈迦様は怒ってないんですけど
本人が受け取ん受けたんですよ
お釈迦様のお返しも結局は
だからお釈迦様怒っているんじゃないかと
今まであんた何言ってる言ってるのかと聞いた方がいいのに
自分が今まで言ったことはチャラ
だから人間っていうのはそういうバカなんですよ
だから笑えるんです それでお釈迦様は説法するんですよ
アッコダッサクトーコードーダンタッサムジーバニ
怒りがなくなくしている人にとっては
怒りがあるわけないでしょうと
心は清らかにして制御している人にはね
興奮 そんなのはないんだよと
サンマダンニャーユムタッサウパサンタッサタージノ
一切の真理を発見して
心を安穏境地に達している人にとってはね
そんなのはないんだよ
怒った人に対して怒りで返したならば
それが一番悪いんだと
例えば A さんが怒る 私に
私は何もやっていないのに
A さんがものすごいガンガン怒っていて
それで私も怒りで返しちゃうと
A さんと私の間で一番悪いのは私なんです
よく覚えてください 誰かが来て皆様に怒ったならば
皆様方は怒り返すでしょ
どちらの方の悪さが重いかというと
怒り返した方の悪さが重いんです
最初に怒った人じゃないんです
なぜかというとね 自分が人の話を聞いて怒ったでしょ
もう汚れてるんですよ
心が それから相手に怒り返すでしょ
また罪も犯しているんです
それで怒った人に怒り返さないならば
その人はすごいことをやっていますよと
両方の役に立ちますよと
相手に対して怒り返さないと
相手の怒りも消えてしまいます
それから自分が自分を戒めたという
怒らないでいることを経験したんだからと
両方の役に立ちますよと
そういうわけで 怒った人に対して怒り返す人は
理性のある人から見れば愚かなことであるとバラモン人に説法したんです
だから 単なる対話の冗談で終わらないんです
それから事実はこういうことだよ
あなた知ってますかと
怒ったら怒り返さないんだよと
怒り返したらもうなおさら悪いんだよと
怒らない人は相手まで直してあげますよと
そう言われたら あのバラモンがよくわかったんです
自分がなんということをしたんですかと
結局本人ももうしょうがない
私も出家しますと こんな偉大なる教えだからね
友達が出家したんだから
腹が立ってお釈迦様を非難
侮辱するために来たんだけど
結局本人も出家して終わっちゃったんです
で 後で瞑想して悟りにも達するんです
だからバラモンは怒らないことの素晴らしさをわかったんです
もう一つ 業について まあどんな経典にもいうのはありますよ
だから選ぶのは大変なんです
ジャイナ教徒のガーミニに聞くというエピソードがありまして
この刀のね 剣の職人だと思いますけど
名前はガーミニ 彼がジャイナ教の信者さんなんです
皆様方はヨガはやるんですけど
ジャイナ教ってあるっていうことは知らないんですね
インドで お釈迦様の時代からもうずっとあるんです
で このやっているヨガのヒンドゥ教よりは結構立派なんですけど
教えも しかし 仏教はかなり気になるんですよ
ジャイナ教はヒンドゥ教よりも
で ガーミニがお釈迦様に会ったんですね
会ったらお釈迦様知ってます
このガーミニ君がジャイナ教徒の信者さんであるということを知って
普通に会話するんです
えーと ガーミニ 君の宗教では
あなたの教祖様がどのように信徒たちを躾しているのでしょうかと
それでガーミニ君が君たちの先生はね
どういう教えで君たちを育てていますか？と聞くんです
すごい優しく聞くんです
ごく一般的な会話なんですよ
それで彼がこういう答え出すんです
教祖様がこのように説く
もし人は殺生 すごい読めない
え？中途でしたっけ？などなどは十悪ありますね
殺生すること 盗ま盗むこと
えーと 邪な行為をすること
嘘を言うこと 悪口を言うこと
無駄話すること 異常な欲
異常な怒り 怒りと邪見という十悪あります
こちら十悪も入ってないんですけど
ジャイナ先生がこう言うんだと
誰かが殺生するならば
みんな地獄に落ちますと
誰かが盗みするならば
みんな地獄に落ちます
誰かが邪な行為をするならば
地獄 誰であろうとも 嘘をつくならば地獄に落ちますよと
我々の先生はそういうことを教えていますよと
それで先生は理由として
ヤンバフランヴィエラティテーナテーナニーヤディ
なぜかというと たくさんやること
習慣的にやることによって
次は決まりますよという答え出すんです
えーと 必ず皆地獄に陥る
なぜならば 人は多数に行う行為によって導かれるということで
癖になったらまあその道に行くんだよと
えらい論理的なんですね
なんか悪いこと言ってないでしょ？嘘を言ったら地獄に落ちますよとかね
誰でも当たり前のこと
正しいこと言ってると思っちゃうでしょ
では お釈迦様の答えを見てみましょう
サクソンが答える ヤンヤンバフランバフランチャガーミニヴィエラティテーナテーナニーヤティエーワンサンテーナコーチアーパイコーネーリコーバビッサティヤターニガンタッサナータプッタッサワチャ
ナ
このジャイナ教の教祖様の名前は見えないな
このニガンタナータプッタなんですね
多数に行う行為によって導かれるとする言葉が正しければ
誰も地獄には陥りませんよと
だって理由はもうたくさん習慣的にやったことをたくさんやっちゃうと地獄に落ちるんだよという話でしょ
それだったらね ガーミニさん
誰も地獄に落ちませんよと
ずいぶん軽々くお釈迦様が言うんです
それで説明するんです
説明はこちらで読みます
タンキンマンニャスガーミニ
ガーミニあなたどう思いますか？ヨープリソーパーナアティパーティーラッティアワーディヴァサッスワーサマヤーサマヤンウパーターヤ
カタモーバフタローサマヨー
ヤンワーソーパーナアティマーパーテーティ
はい 誰かが殺生するとしましょう
その人は昼間か夜か 夜か昼か
その時その時殺生するとしましょう
しかし どんな時間長いんですかと
殺生する時間と殺生しない時間
どちらが長いんですかと
どちら長いんですかね
殺生 生命を殺す人がいる
その人はまあ その時その時
気が向いたら 朝であろうか
昼であろうか 午後であろうか
夜であろうか 殺生はする
しかし その人の殺生者の一日の中で
長い時間何をやっているのかと
殺生しているいるか 殺生していないのかというと
ガーミニさんが まあやっぱり殺生しない時間長いんだよと答えるんです
それだったらね 彼がたくさんやっているのは殺生しないことだと
一日の中で 殺生した時間というのはほんのわずか短いんですよと
だから一日の長い時間殺生しないでいたんだからね
その行方に導かれますよと
ということは 殺生しても地獄に落ちないんだよという理由なんです
ことになるんです だから
あなたの先生が言ってる話が正しければ
誰も地獄に落ちませんよと
だから理屈をしっかり壊しちゃったんです
言ってることは間違いだと
それで全部 1項目ずつ切るんです
じゃあ嘘をつく人を見てみましょうと
人は嘘をつくんだと しかし
その人は嘘をつく時間と嘘をついてない時間
比較するとどっちの方が長いんですかと
だから長くやったことによって次の運命決めるでしょ
そうすると 嘘をつかない時間長いんだから
残念なことに嘘をついたっても地獄に落ちませんということになるんです
あんた方大失敗だとということを言ってるんです
だからジャイナ教の先生がこのニガンタナータプッタと言うんです
ニガンタナータプッタ先生が人々に嘘をついてはいけませんよと言いたいんですよ
殺生してはいけませんよと
道徳を教えたいんだけど
教えてるのは反対 だからまあ
この完璧に語るということは
仏教はすごい厳しいんです
これ 完璧でないところ
すぐお釈迦様が引っかかっちゃうんだよ
指を指すんです 指してこのにこっと笑って言うんです
そこでまた逆襲するんだよ
お釈迦様が それでわかるでしょう？あんたはね
言っていることは間違っていると
結局は誰も地獄に落ちないような話でしょ
しているのは この間違った意見を持つことは
間違った意見を持つことは邪見でしょ？って言うんです
それで 先生は邪見でいて
先生の邪見を聞いて 生徒たちも邪見に陥っているでしょ
しかし この考え方はずっと持ってますね
邪見だけはよく覚えてください
だから 殺生した人が地獄に必ず落ちるというような邪見がありますね
理由はたくさん時間やったんだからっていう
そこで殺生はたまたまするんだけど
意見はずっと持ってるでしょ
意見持ってる時間と意見持ってない時間ないでしょ
意見の場合はずっと持ってますね
そこは怖いんです 嘘をつく場合は
その時その時必要に応じて嘘をついたりつかなかったりする
しかし 我々持っている意見というものは
ずっと 24時間持ってます
夢を見ている時でも 意見に逆らった夢は見ません
それでお釈迦様は言うんです
私はね 邪見を持つ人はもう直行で畜生に畜生に生まれるか
地獄に生まれるか どちらかと解きますよと
そういうことでですね
あなたの先生とあなたたちはね
ということで終わるんです
話は 結局 お釈迦様が全部逆にしてしまうんですね
殺生した人は地獄に落ちますよと大念処経様が言うんだけど
本当に地獄に落ちるのは誰ですかね
ジャイナ教祖様とその弟子たちなんです
だからその間違った意見は捨てない限りはもう地獄に落ちますよと
殺生する人がいるとしましょう
その人生でどちらの時間が多いのですか？と今言いましたね
明らかに殺生しないでいる時間が多いのです
ん？それなら殺生しても地獄には陥りませんと
間違っている考えは邪見です
邪見を持つ人に死後道は 2つです
地獄か畜生です ですから
地獄か畜生に生まれるのは
その開祖様とその教えを信じる生徒たちではないでしょうかと
それなら悪をなくす法
それから悪をなくす方法を教えるんです
それで終わらないんです
相手をからかって言っていることは間違っていると言って
冗談だけで終わらないんです
それから延々とお釈迦様が悪ってどういうことかと説明していくんです
お釈迦様はいうのは 仏教の世界ではね
ブッダが現れて ブッダが殺生は悪いんだと
だから皆様殺生をやめなさいというと
盗みは悪い やめましょうと
よこしまな行為は悪い
やめましょうと 嘘は悪い
やめましょうと 私は喋ると
私の話に話を気に入る弟子たちが現れますよと
この弟子たちは この先生
お釈迦様がもうずっと殺生の悪口言うわ
盗みは悪いというわ 批判するわ
よこしまな行為を批判するわ
嘘をつくことは批判するわ
なんですけど 私はね 時々やっちゃいますよと
お釈迦様が嘘をつくなよと言ってもね
私は結構身に覚えがあるんだよと
と思うんだよと なんだらかんだら言いながら
私は殺生しているんだよと
なんだらかんだら言いながら
私は盗んだり 物を取ったりするんだよと
と弟子は思うんだと 正直に
それでその弟子が これはかっこ悪い
いくらなんでもかっこ悪い
かっこ悪い だからやめますと
これから殺生をやめます
盗みやめますと 嘘をやめます
よこしまなことやめますと
いうことでやめるんだよと
その人はそれからも殺生しないように生活するんだよと
それで お釈迦様は何の問題もなく道徳を設定して見せてあげるんです
それで人々はそういう十悪から心を離れると
心がすごくきれいになるんだよと
お出かけになるんだよと
それからその人は四方八方に対して怒りと欲をなくして
慈悲喜捨 慈しみで生活するんだよ
で 慈悲の瞑想しましたからね
それで この慈悲喜捨の瞑想っていうのは無料なんです
一切の生命だから 無条件で慈しみを育てる
まず悪いことをやめる
悪いことをやめて慈悲の実践に入ると
そうすると無料のことをやっています
無料の善行為は無制限
それで無制限に善行為をしている人にとっては
ちょこちょこと人を殺したことがあったってもね
そんなのは全然無効になっちゃいますよと
だから無料の善行為があって
有料と言わないね 限りのある
ちょっとちょっと罪があるでしょうね
人 人ではなくて 生命を殺したこともあるし
嘘をついたこともあるし
ちょこちょこと不倫やったこともあるとかね
そういう まあなんかなんかまあ犯した罪はありますけど
本人が今無制限無料の善行為をしているんです
それで大丈夫でしょうと
だから 犯した罪に対しては何もできない
黙れということなんです
その罪が結果出ませんでしょう
あなたにはと 私は今すごい上司に状況にいるんだと
そういうふうに教えると
人々は悪をやめて善の道歩むんです
理性があるならばですよ
理性がなかったらもうどうしようもないんです
私は罪を犯ったことがあるんだ
そこを泣いたりはしません
見てください 普通だったら悔い改めなさい
後悔しなさいとかね 何言ってるんですかと
仏教徒はたとえ罪を犯したっても
全然気にもしない それはもう認めます
いくらなんでも なんだらかんだら仏教徒と言いながらね
私はこんなことこれかっこ悪いんだからね
とにかくやめますと やめて
心清らかにして 慈悲喜捨の慈しみの気持ちで生活してやるぞと
そして偉大なる善行為に入ってしまうんです
それでこの罪が無効になるんです
そういうことで 地獄に落ちそう
地獄に落ちる 脅すことってかっこ悪いんです
だから間違ってる宗教は人を脅すんです
お釈迦様は脅してないんです
罪を犯した人にも何も言ってないんです
悪いことからかってるんです
だから私の弟子たちはね
私はもうさんざん殺生は悪いと言うとね
なんだらかんだら言いながら
私はやったことあるんだよと正直に認めるだけ
だからそこですごくなんかニコニコという笑いがあるんです
パーリ語で言うとこう笑いますよ
いくらなんでもお釈迦様はもうすごい徹底的に批判しますけど
でも私はね これやとかという言葉で書いてありますから
しかし 誰でも本当に幸福の方に行くように教えています
脅してないんです だから言うだけでは終わってないということを覚えておいてください
仏教